Hello world,
it's Saroj and how are you
supposed to start an AI startup?
I'm going to go over the steps
you need to take to do this.
Using a combination of my own startup
experience and analyzing some best
practices that some recently successful
AI startups have implemented.
The public's interest in AI will continue
to rise in the coming years and we're
just at the start of a
larger AI revolution.
Innovative startups continue to pop up
every single week. Tetra, for example,
uses recent advances in speech recognition
to generate detailed notes from your
phone calls.
Hyper science extracts data from
forms easily using optical character
recognition and jet lore uses consumer
behavior as input to a model able to
output structured data. So it's
2018 and you want to get in on this.
Your first step is to study AI.
You can't create an AI solution if
you yourself don't understand how this
amazing technology works,
right?
I've got some great free playlists for
you to help you get started with this.
If you're just getting started,
watch them in this order.
Learn Python for data science,
then intro to tensorflow,
then intro to deep learning and lastly
the math of intelligence. Additionally,
Andrew Ng's newer deep learning that
AI course is a must have and Jeremy
Howard's fast on AI course
is excellent as well.
My favorite book on deep learning is the
deep learning book by Ian Goodfellow.
It's free online and where it really
excels is in helping you get to terms with
the math of deep learning.
Deep learning has proven to outperform
every other ml model almost every time on
a wide range of tasks so the
hype is justified. However,
you should really know how the other
machine learning models work because there
are use cases where you don't have access
to a lot of data and you just need to
make a simple prediction.
In those cases,
support vector machines or even a simple
decision tree would be a more useful
approach than a deep neural network.
The only way to know what model to use
and when to use it is to develop an
intuition and that comes after studying
using a wide variety of sources.
All the ones I've talked about
will be in the description.
Once you've got a grasp of the
landscape of algorithms that make up AI,
you've got to find a problem
that you feel passionate about.
Some of the most successful companies
in the world were started because the
founders were trying to solve a
problem that they themselves faced.
Write down a list of problems that
you or your friends have faced in your
personal lives that you would like solved.
These will very likely be good candidates
for problems that you are passionate
about solving since those affected are
people that you very much care about.
If you can't think of any good ones,
you could also use social media to search
proactively for people looking for a
solution.
Search in quotes for words and phrases
that indicate that the poster is
frustrated by something or looking to
solve a problem like how do I or can't
seem to this.
We'll work on Reddit,
Twitter just about any community where
a target market might congregate on,
but perhaps the best way that I've found
to find problems is to travel and meet
people.
I couch surfed around Europe for three
months a few years ago and happened to
stay with Alex Maccaw in London.
He gave me the inspiration necessary to
change my trajectory in my early years
of university from economics
to computer science,
one of the most impactful
changes I'd made in my life.
It's what got me to eventually start
a robotics startup, lucid robotics.
While I was a third year
student at Columbia and more
recently traveling through
South and South East Asia for four months
helped put things into perspective for
me.
I left the bubble of Silicon Valley and
got to see problems firsthand that real
people faced in their day to day lives,
problems related to infrastructure,
banking, communication,
and of course education.
That was the one that really affected me.
Simple conversations I had with locals
compounded into later experiences that
resulted in a larger plan to educate
the world on AI by making my content the
product as you,
Elon Musk says,
being an entrepreneur is like eating
glass and staring into the abyss of death.
If you don't have the
passion to solve a problem,
you're not going to stick around.
When the going gets tough.
No matter how many negative
comments I've gotten,
I've always persevered
because it's not about me.
It's about solving AI.
Once you have a problem to solve,
it's time to do some market research.
Who are you selling to?
Where are they going to buy it?
How much would they pay?
What are the competing products
or services in this space?
What's the cost to deploy? What does
the history of this market look like?
Usually.
Dot.
Gov's and big data analytics firms have
publicly available reports on this.
Generally AI startups,
our class into two varieties.
There are the horizontal AI startups.
These are working on one fundamental
problem that would serve many different
industries like say,
general natural language processing.
Then there's the vertical AI startups.
These are solving problems for a very
specific type of customer belonging to one
specific industry.
Just about every major tech company
is working really actively on AI.
They're able to hire all the Ai Rock
stars from Hinton [inaudible], Macoun.
They've got the talent,
they've got the massive amounts of data
they've collected from users over the
years, which remains closed only
to their teams. These tech giants,
a huge advantage when it comes
to building horizontal products.
That can apply to many industries like
image recognition or language translation
or infrastructure.
But the advantage of that you have is
that you can move fast on a single problem
vertically. They don't have the time
to tackle every single niche problem,
but you do.
And as a whole,
they're focused on the consumer more
than they're focused on the enterprise.
So a niche solution that would help
companies would be a great choice.
Create a landing page that describes your
product with a simple email signup to
get notified of release and
share it on social media.
One way to raise awareness of your
product is to raise your own personal
profile,
establish herself as an AI thought leader,
create blog posts or other content that
answers fundamental questions about Ai.
Build an audience, see if you
get any signups. If you do,
especially after you've stated what
the price of your product will be,
it means there's a demand for what you
could be offering. This is crucial.
I went through the whole
process of raising money,
building a product and the team,
my last startup only to find that the
elder care market didn't want a $5,000
robot to help pick
things up off the floor.
People with als would much
prefer a simpler tool.
I was too obsessed with the solution.
Not The problem.
If you remove AI from the company,
but it still has a valuable product,
you're on the right track,
but if AI is your only thing,
then neither the customer nor
investors will be excited about it.
Once you've done your market research,
it's time to build a product,
but before you build a model,
you've got to collect, organize,
and label your data as much as you can.
The quality of the data is usually
the most important part of the machine
learning pipeline, even more so
than the architecture of your model.
The phrase garbage in,
garbage out to comes to mind.
The easy way to get data is
to search for public datasets.
There's an awesome list
of datasets on get hub.
The University of California.
Earvin has a giant ml repository of
data sets and of course Kaggle has some
great ones as well.
If those don't work.
Another way is to create data
yourself using an existing data set,
like if you're trying to
classify handwritten characters,
you could generate new data points from
existing ones by adding some noise via a
distribution.
If you've got unlabeled data,
crowd sourcing via Amazon's
Mechanical Turk is a great option.
You could pay people to label it for you.
There are also data marketplaces out there
like data circle where you can buy or
exchange data sets directly
from other people. Lastly,
if you're feeling creative,
you can scrape the data yourself using
python in a library like scrap high or a
web service that does this for you,
like dig or not.com.
When it comes to building models,
tensor flow is still the best,
most battle tested machine
learning framework out there
and there's a whole host
of tools in the tensorflow ecosystem
like tensorflow serving that,
make it production ready,
build a model and train it on
your data via a service like AWS,
Google cloud or Floyd hub.
Use Your model to make a prediction
and this is your product.
More data means smarter
algorithms means better products,
means more users,
means better data and the cycle repeats.
Raising money is a way to
accelerate the scaling process.
The ICO route may be hot right now,
but if you're in it for the longterm
and don't want to mess around with
legalities,
I'd avoid this for now.
A friend of mine who was the first
designer for Atherium didn't do an ICO for
his company balance.
He instead raised money using a crowd
funding tool called the we funder.
He's reasons were really inspiring
and I've got an article on it in the
description. Venture capital
is of course another option,
and while it's easy to convince some
vcs that your product is cool by just
repeating a bunch of buzz words,
the best ones will understand
the technology well,
so be prepared to explain the
technicalities of it to them.
You're always in a better position to
talk to vcs when you've already got to
cashflow than if you don't.
That's why I got rejected
by so many vcs in New York.
I hadn't proven my robot would sell.
Now I've got a few offers to invest
in what I'm doing since I've built an
audience so I can afford to be picky,
but I'm not focused on raising money
right now. When it comes to hiring,
there's a limited supply of talent
and it's distributed globally,
so it makes sense to hire globally.
Look at the leaderboard on Kaggle.
The first hires you make
are the most important.
I worked really hard to find the right
fit to help me with editing my videos.
If you really love something,
it's hard to ever let go control of it,
but if you find the right person,
it becomes much easier.
As Steve Jobs said,
the newest thing that happens is when
you get a core group of, uh, you know,
10 great people that it becomes self
policing as to who they let into that
group.
At some point,
you'll be able to exit,
whether that be through an aqua hire or
buy one of the big tech companies or an
IPO. And if all else fails, there's
always the consulting route.
It's not as sexy as building a product,
but hey, it puts bread on the table.
Find a couple of friends
and start a consulting firm.
Get some initial clients and slowly
get more impressive brands on board.
As you prove yourself,
I hope my tips help.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to start up to grow.
So thanks for watching.